[Music]  Rembrandt his name is synonymous with  master fees and this arguably one of his  greatest paintings iconic work of  individuals setting aside their  differences for a common good but what  we see is not what people saw hundreds  of years ago how we see changes because  our senses are evolving  [Music]  since eights by their nature are a  threat to secrecy I'm looking for better  future  whose happen  do not trust any of them  it is not a game this is a war your life  is either defined by the system but by  the way you defy the system as long as  we're together I know that there's  nothing we can do  [Music]  while my Who am I you think you're  hunting us  we're coming for you  well it's a long story